[Music]
in uber nightmare news
Barbeau Joe heaven she got famous from
doing story time so fall her over
nightmares yeah I got [ __ ] with the
toothbrush that one yeah those videos
what's that yeah this was like huge new
mojo few years ago these people do knock
you back it's like click Betty she
didn't get far with you brush I think
that's [ __ ] up watch the video cuz I
was like this is clickbait not a lot
fault I clicked it and she didn't get
[ __ ] with the - I think she did get
[ __ ] with a toothbrush but not in the
boys story - but she probably [ __ ]
herself the toothbrush and that's
different what's the point I agree
it's like good cleaning if I was a girl
I'd get those electric toothbrush and
[ __ ] trap myself in a room all day
you don't know what it feels rushing my
teeth I play with my titties literally
all day long literally all day you what
put in your teeth I would play with my
titties I do there's no way you actually
get bored there's no when I'm like you
have anxiety I just kind of play with
one of my boobs that I'm like that's
kind of can't take them with me I don't
have a stress ball on my person but I
mean I guess we could but it'd be weird
if we're just like random like right now
like I just don't feel right touchin you
feel real weird we don't be like oh this
is so wrong I can't stop touching mine
now that's our usual friend it's kind of
comfortable yeah right and then you're
like this is so squishy here yeah that's
nice that's nice I got some goodies
mm-hmm this was submitted by Blake got
tank
we're cool Blake thanks Brian and action
and uber driver went back to burglarize
a home after dropping his passengers off
at the airport that's [ __ ] up
I've always thought about that me too
but then I'm like I don't live in a nice
home that's they're not picking me up on
my door cuz I live like in the common
yeah see I'm not like you don't know
where I live how would they know that
they were the only ones there living
there they probably told them they got
the information while they were having
long conversations yeah home alone where
they found out the timing of the
and they knew that nobody was there
because of the timing of the life we
knew yeah you didn't know no remember
when he shows to the Christmas lights
he's like that house goes on then that
house and that house God about that he
goes timers they're all on timers
because everyone's out on vacation and
that's how they knew that people were I
remember the Michael Jordan scene where
he's like on a train goes by the window
it's Michael Jordan cardboard cutout oh
yeah yeah right in a row I basically
always fast forwarded to where they're
like renovating the house that's the
best part the first part like you take
it where they where they were talking to
the guy outside the airport saying like
oh yeah we're here by ourselves and then
they get taken yep all this information
with strangers I lie to my uber drivers
Oh what do you do for work plumbing make
[ __ ] up that's the perfect time to be
anybody who you want to but plumbing
plumbers or ballers dude don't say
plumbing hey some other [ __ ] good you're
not in a Hoover black do right plumbers
can make a hundred a year you're an
apprentice plumber thank you I know I
always have to like nudge Casey when
Casey so friendly I know but he's like
think too much I'm like dude our Social
Security car
I'm a new bird and they're like what do
you do and I'm like I Drive Ober what
are you gonna do now I bill if I'm off
right now I'm off to do going to
McDonald's on your lunch break when you
work at McDonald's
hey they do that yeah you see the
workers over chillin there I sure that's
cheaper for you know why cuz I eat
inside you know why cuz I'm sad let's
talk about it yeah this took place here
in California but in San Mateo where's
that I'm McNeal it's like an hour from
census it's a good neighborhood is a
good neighborhood I found these well you
wouldn't rob a bad neighborhood oh my
guess you would
bad neighborhoods typically have less
security and more cash in the house good
neighborhoods you're not too sure
valuables yeah but how about how can you
have valuables but they don't keep cash
because most people have money in the
bank you know bad neighborhoods have
those white bars no window wouldn't that
be better security they never stopped me
my experience to get back those bars
because of sliding doors oh you don't
know divulge too much information you
haven't seen that movie Friday where the
guy just sticks a knife and goes like
this and pricks it open yeah that's how
the ghetto the ghetto gates or sources
think about it no one goes through
windows well some people do but samachar
are huh then that's when you have the
home alone contraption the intruder yeah
well yeah so this man his name is Jackie
38 years old he's an uber driver he was
caught on the couples ring the doorbell
that's good how do people not know about
the ring anymore I know everyone's
getting collared the ring I don't know
what the ring is what is it it's like a
doorbell and has a camera like a nest
yeah yeah but it's just a camera
doorbell yeah and then you get
notifications to your phone yeah I mean
they always have this on the news and I
don't know how these deeds don't know
right well I'm glad that they do don't
know dude I love the footage there's
some footage out there ring feet of
thieves that are coming in to ring
houses and they literally like put their
face up to the camera yeah [ __ ] is this
they get their entire faded but you
could stand there [ __ ] it right now I
like to do those licking the doorknob
yeah what the view staring right into
the [ __ ] yeah I get notifications all
the time and they're like why is this
guy standing like this and he's standing
at the door he's just like that only in
the morning is [ __ ] your place
not my place I just get these
notifications because of the
neighborhood oh no so where is that in
your neighborhood our neighborhood I
think the law of being able to shoot
somebody the castle should be up to your
sidewalk wait
it's not in California it's inside your
house and you have to be an immediate
danger so if they turn their back on you
immediately
you can't shoot them and if you do then
you're [ __ ] oh come on if you rob
somebody you want to rob them like this
it's really good you can't do it I know
like don't damn it the castle aw [ __ ]
we don't have the castle because like
once there on your property like
anywhere right and you could get your
gun I don't know about that cuz it's
like that's Texas in other states but I
don't yeah but I think it even applies
to your car mmm
so he got caught on this doorbell ring
yes I started googling the castle lot
okay let me show you the video
and they're like wait that's our uber
driver well so they got so the couple
that was dropped off at the airport
they got this notification and then I
guess this dude got scared off because
they had an alarm system and then in the
same thing the neighborhood during app
there was another video posted saying
like hey you know like does anyone know
who this guy is I put our place is
robbed and into the same look we're
dragons act and then so they were able
to catch his license-plate number from
the surveillance of the neighborhood hmm
and that's how he was caught and when he
was arrested the next day she was still
wearing the same clothes he was wearing
his showers he's been wearing hats too
much good yeah 10 he for sure this or
just a visor mm-hmm hey Jackie
yeah that's dangerous I think a state
that's a little worse than us in
self-protection is Hawaii they have this
one law it's called like a it's like a
there's a name for it like you know
there's like a castle law or whatever
but it's like a passive state or
whatever where if you hear somebody
breaking into your house you're you
can't send them off you just got out if
there's a way that you can escape you're
supposed to run away and just let the
burglar yeah just take whatever they
want and it's like a non-violent because
there are those stories about how the
burglar would try to sneak in through
the roof and then they fell and broke
your leg Californians
that's amazing judges like why's your
chimney not have stairs inside yeah so
after they went to jail they came back
and they sued the house that yeah isn't
that crazy it's kind of eerie though cuz
like they don't they don't do a lot of
background checks on these uber drivers
like anyone could be like there was a
great amount raped there was yeah I was
just thinking about that now that like
I'm a dad I was like okay maybe I could
do some ubering when my wife and baby
goes to sleep make some extra cash I was
like you know if I pick up a fan that's
kind of weird
mmm so what if I get an uber application
put my dad's name on it and then drive
and get a bank account I could work
because they wouldn't never know that's
true you could now you just talked about
how you're gonna [ __ ] it that's why I
don't like alone sometimes lyft and uber
driver oh really
like here no in Texas a lot and a guy
like left a note when he left saying
like you know like he would like to buy
her for some sexy times was it oh I
don't know but yeah it's just kind of
like the being a single lady I know I
almost I was this close to doing it to
to be a lyft and uber driver it was
before I started assisting for you guys
yeah because I had stopped working at
the hospital and I was like oh [ __ ] I
neither like somehow see money so I did
apply to do all that [ __ ] the only last
step I needed to do is perhaps to have
them inspect my car which I never did
for both apps but I almost did it too
and I was so scared doesn't like [ __ ]
what made you change your mind cuz I
didn't want to do it and then plus like
Bart Bart Joe and David were like hey
you could be our personal assistant I'm
like thank you guys living lucrative to
be an uber or lyft track I heard now
it's not
not bad but this was years ago that's
just I was just talking to this Hawaii
goober guy cuz I was just there
and I took bunch of goobers this guy
makes 3,000 a week
oh wow that's a lot like a 50 hour
weekend all right
it was something like that it was like
card takes a clerk I don't remember
maybe 30 40 hours of some [ __ ] like that
I'm still 12 grand a month that's pretty
good that's [ __ ] sick bro yeah maybe
I lied my pen on area like you might be
in a high tourist high-traffic area yeah
so move to why I make 12 grand a month
[ __ ] come on now that's tight I mean
cuz when you drive to the airport you
get those flat fees and they're like 50
bucks every time no matter how far or
close it is maybe that's why I don't
know yeah so an uber spokesperson said
that that driver obviously is no longer
on their app and that if riders are
worried about the situation happening to
them like an uber driver knowing where
they live it's like their exact address
they can also you know put a cross
street and they could walk to the cross
street so the uber driver doesn't know
where the exact house is here's a tip
put it on your neighbor's house you come
out of your house I'll be honest with
you mr. driver I am a rich man anyway
and I'm never home I just died just
don't come home I don't trust the banks
keep my cash yeah how about you sir do
you trust banks oh man you shouldn't
leave everything under my bed yeah every
dollar I've ever and I keep under my bed
you know what else I keep under my bed
naked women random naked women me huh
yeah that's right
there they wanted me there
[Music]